hey everybody welcome to the lady in
Wonderland although today it's probably
better to say silver at in Wunderland
since I'm taking over the park for a bit
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
with it
the lady in Wonderland is video series
by the lady's honor where she builds
Wunderland which is a very fairy tale
fantasy style Park as you can tell that
very heavily focuses on scenery now
it's an amazing looking park and like I
said she's done some amazing scenery out
here also in collaboration with SP
Ridley who has done some amazing work on
it as well and it already has two
different themed areas here the main
area and a spooky area and some
different flat rides and dark ride but
what it doesn't have yet is a roller
coaster and truth be told roller
coasters are more of an interest of mine
than of the lady's honor so we figured
that this would be a good crossover to
get me into the series and just build a
roller coaster here real quick and then
get out of it and she'll have to dress
it up and add some scenery to it so if
you want to see how this roller coaster
is going to end up and what the rest of
the park looks like definitely go check
out the playlist I'll leave it down in
description and also leave a link to the
channel as well if you still haven't
found that somehow and yeah I think it's
better to get into the time-lapse and
I'll explain a little bit more along the
way so on an island in the spooky area
of the park which already features a
haunted house and train station and some
other stuff a general sort of haunted
woods area there is there's this island
and he wanted to have a roller coaster
on it but she figured that I would be a
little bit better at building it then
she would be and to be honest it was
actually kind of happy when she asked
because I was really just aching to
build a roller coaster and I was in so
much looking forward to doing scenery
that day so I just shoved my own
projects aside and built this roller
coaster so yeah that's basically what
happened and what I decided to go for
after a bit of trying to work with the
Mariana X car is actually a girl our
Eurofighter and the reason being is that
you can probably tell that this is a
very small strip of land
on this island there is not a lot of
space and it's a launched coaster that's
also very compact and that's something
that I really felt would fit on the
island quite well also something that I
had to keep in mind is that this right
side of the island is going to have
castle on it so there's going to be a
bit of a weenie and I wanted to leave
some space for some architectural parts
and also try and get some interesting
play between the coaster and the scenery
to get that interaction going so I
wanted something that would Milo most of
the time while also being able to be a
very compact coaster while at the same
time also being a very thrilling ride
and a Eurofighter I felt would really be
the best thing to fit in here so we ever
launched Eurofighter which has that
launch aside the water which is quite
nice because it means that you can see
the mountains from all the paths around
the island which is also some
interesting attraction if you have
something like a launch you definitely
want to show it as much as you can and
from that we go into a top hat which I
originally thought would go into a curve
straightaway but that probably resulted
in some pretty bad laterals and also it
was a bit too quickly and I really
wanted to have a sort of long winding
curve that would actually go over the
water so I decided to just finish the
top hat normally and then get into the
curve and at this point it's actually
inspired by the very standard
Eurofighter layouts the stuff like
cannonball Kenobi which is just a layout
where you normally have the little and
the beyond vertical drop into the loop
and it kind of just finishes off with a
barrel roll some helixes and some curves
and that's basically what this layout is
going to do as well except instead of
the little which I thought would look
kind of ugly and take attention away
from the castle which is going to stand
on the island I would go for a launch
which hopefully should also make for a
little bit more of an exciting ride
because it means that we can actually
pull some mad airtime on top of that and
sort of that top hat which it actually
does it's kind of a fast launch I think
84 kilometers an hour
kind of like God I can't pronounce it
but kind of like flew from North Col
Road in Hunter Park which I took the
idea from that and launched in your
fighting like this might actually work
quite well and from that we go into the
sort of standard loop that we have on
Euro fighters which is a little bit
circular I try to get the shape in as
well as I could in the end I still think
it's a little bit slightly too fats more
flat than I was going for but in the end
I'm quite happy with how the loop works
it was just kind of a hassle to get it
done since I really had to build a
custom loop to go for that slightly more
roundish shaping I'm not entirely sure
why euro fighters have this sort of
rounded loop I've only been on one but
it's certainly it's something that it
rides fine actually think that the loop
is is quite good but normally loops are
much more much more tear drop shaped
than mess to go from work even forces
that's said your fighters too often have
quite a bit of hang time in their
inversions that probably goes for girl
hour coasters in general so I also
wanted to make up for some of the hang
time here so we have a very slow moving
barrel roll which I'm working on over
here it's actually the only part of the
coaster that I decided to make in four
metre long pieces only problem with that
is that I can't really make it very
smooth since none of the rest of the
coaster is based on four metre long
pieces and I can't really use the
smoothing method that well because the
transitions from the regular linked
pieces into four metre long pieces is
quite hard but I guess the pro of doing
the barrel roll this way is that it is
actually hard lined so it's going to be
a bit rough and very jerky around the
transitions but hey at least it's hard
lined and in this case I kind of went
for track shaping over smoothness so
that's something that I went for anyway
and then with another turn which is
going through the loop which was
something that I didn't entirely plan
but
I'm not really complaining because
actually looks pretty cool we're getting
into another area of the island now I
try to make this this as compact as
possible so I'm really trying to use as
much space of the island as I can to get
as much closer track in as I can but I
also wanted the most of the track to be
elevated above the ground a little bit
because there also needs to be room for
the cue you might have noticed that my
station is actually on the island has
been thinking of doing a station outside
the island in a Big Thunder Mountain
kind of way but the problem with that
was usually that Big Thunder Mountain
works because it has live fills and it
just has a lift hill to bring you up to
the island again but in this case I
wanted to go for a launch coaster and a
coaster that launches out of the river
and onto the island was something that
seemed like a fun idea but this seems
like it makes more sense and it's a
little bit more realistic and easy to
work with so I'm going for the slightly
more safe option
I suppose here by having the station on
the island it just means that I have to
fill in the queue for the station as
well so as per Mogis kira fighters
ending this off with a small helix over
here which means that we're pulling some
nice vertical G's throughout this ride
and also he because are just quite easy
to make we also have some snappy
transitions on top of the hills and you
might have noticed it really goes from
some very heavy banking into another
part of a very heavy banking so in terms
of the shaping I'm actually pretty happy
with this coaster it's definitely not
the smoothest that I've made but be
honest and this is just personal
preference but I kind of prefer drag
shaping over smoothness especially when
it comes down to realism since a
perfectly smooth track is something that
you cannot get to anyway there's really
no way to get to that without the
continuous ball and with a strange way
that splines work in Planet coasters so
I'd rather sacrifice a bit more of this
moving to get to the shaping that I want
to then actually getting a perfectly
smooth track that's slightly differently
shaped than what I would go for
so yeah with that final helix the layout
is done we have a very very steep final
brake run since there was just a lot of
ground to be made up or put in the end
I'm quite happy with that and it also
gives us more room to work with queue
and I also wanted to add Emma q I only
had to make a coaster for lady since
that was basically what I'm here for
but since I left such a terrible puzzle
on the island with all of these supports
and the very tight space that the
coaster is going through I figured I
could also just make media queue and not
have to make her worry about that
although I won't be doing any person
ring and oh just a quick thing that I
also kind of wanted to talk about there
is no official anything that that I
found on the internet about this but
when it comes to Eurofighter launches or
when it comes to girls Lowery's launches
in general they always have this tiny
little dip before they go into the
station I'm pretty sure that this is
because they're mi M launches if I
remember correctly in any case there are
magnetic launches so they work by
switching the poles of magnets or in any
case switching between magnets I'm not
an engineer I don't know the exact
details between it but it works by
having a coaster be attracted to the
magnets in front of it and repelled by
the magnets behind it and doing that
very quickly to make sure that the
oyster is launched so what I think is
that it needs some speed to get going
because you cannot launch a magnetic
launch from a standstill position at
least not as easily I know this quickly
but I'm not 100% sure on this and I
haven't been able to find any sources on
this so if anybody knows for sure and
know is where you could find any info
about that that's something that I'm
really looking for but this is not a
request in any way it's just something
that I've been wondering because I'm
pretty sure it's because of the magnetic
launch but it's something which the
internet seems to be devoid of
information about in any case as a final
thing I just wanted to add some supports
over the barrel roll I actually forgot
to record my cinematics after I'd added
the support so the cinematics at the end
are actually without these supports
but um it's something that's in the
coaster Indian because the barrel rolls
theory under supported in any case
that's the coaster that's currently
nameless so I would like to thank you
guys for watching hope you enjoyed this
quick video where I'm just working on
the coaster layout it's something that I
really enjoy doing and something that I
may be but too little in my videos so
hopefully this makes up for it a little
bit and I'll leave you guys with some
cinematic shots of the coaster bye guys
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]